hey guys how you doing
hey good how are you i'm good so i feel
like the rest of the world i was
obsessed with bridgerton season one and
season two so this is so up my alley i
had so much fun watching this frida why
are you so excited to be part of this
period piece um
i'm i'm excited to be part of this
period piece for the exact same reason
why you're so excited to watch bridgeton
you're kind of seeing it in a different
light you're seeing it with all of these
fun stories that uh we've never seen
them
the way that they're seeing them now
we made the short film about four years
ago and
hoped to make a feature film right away
and while that didn't happen um what we
do
what i what i am seeing now is this
thirst for seeing these stories told in
a way that actually feels more accurate
and more inclusive than just
you know white people playing lovers and
white people scheming and and it's like
it's like we don't do any of that hello
so i'm i'm loving the accuracy of um in
terms of representation in this film and
i'm hoping it continues
yeah i completely agree i love that so
much i love everybody in this i feel
like i instantly was connected to every
single character um
what makes mr malcolm so irresistible
so sorry i didn't hear the question got
cut out oh no
um this was for shoppe uh what makes mr
malcolm so irresistible
i don't know
maybe you'll have to tell me
another look on your face you almost
knew the answer to it
okay so let me ask this what was your
favorite part about playing mr malcolm
i think his complexity was really
intriguing to me
and how he coped with his own
insecurities his anxieties he made
mistakes he was complicated
but also like that he had this well of
emotion that he wasn't comfortable
sharing until he found the right person
to share it with
i love that what makes selena so
irresistible to him
oh my god can you question it
no we can't we can but
that's probably a question for him right
yes yes
uh what makes the
her openness and her vivacity and
everything that he was trying to sort of
like curate by the list she had in space
but didn't need he didn't need the list
to find her you know she was spontaneous
and she shook him up and she was so
engaging and she was so beautiful you
know
she swept him off his feet for sure
i loved watching the whole thing play
out it was so fun all right so if we
know mr malcolm has this list of
qualities that he's looking for in a
bride frida what is the quality at the
top of your list when it comes to a
partner
um just someone who is open to
learning more about my culture and
embracing it and kind of celebrating it
as much as as as i do so
you know i think that's that's that for
me is super important
i love that answer sharpie what about
you the number one call it quality for
you and looking for a partner
number one
um
maybe someone who makes my hearts
flutter when i look into their eyes you
know
something as simple as that why not
but so important awesome thank you so
much you guys congrats on the film have
a great day thank you